تسرب سيئ إلى حد ما للرئيس بايدن
قبل بضع ساعات فقط أثناء
بدء أكاديمية القوات الجوية في كولورادو
سبرينغز ، دعونا نتوجه مباشرة إلى
فيل مانينغلي فيل من سي إن إن.
لقد كان تقليدًا قديمًا
يحضر فيه القائد العام
تخريج أكاديمية الخدمة ، وهو جزء من
هذا الجهد كجزء من حضوره ، ومن
التقليدي أن يعطي ملاحظات
الرئيس التي أدلى بها 35 دقيقة من الملاحظات
ثم يوزعها على كل خريج.  كل
كاديت حصل على شهادته التي
حصل عليها الرئيس لأكثر من 90 دقيقة
لتبادل التحية ، لكن هذا
كان إلى حد كبير ما تم تحديده في تلك
اللحظة حتى استدار الرئيس
بعد أن حصل آخر كاديت على
شهادته للعودة إلى مقعده في تلك
اللحظة.  تعثرت على ما يبدو
أنه كيس رمل وتعرض لسقوطًا سيئًا ، حيث تمت
مساعدته على العودة ، ثم عاد على الفور
إلى مقعده دون مساعدة
الآن يقول البيت الأبيض إنه بخير.
قال إنه بخير تمامًا